[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Today I'm
going to show you
how to get started using EDB
Postgres Enterprise Database
in Google Cloud Launcher.
EDB Postgres Enterprise provides
comprehensive management,
integration, and Oracle
compatibility and migration
tools, as well as services
and 24/7 global support.
From the EDB Postgres
Enterprise landing
page on the Cloud Launcher site,
click Launch on Compute Engine.
This will take you to the Select
or Create a Project, where
you can make your selection.
Next, you'll be taken to
the Deployment Configuration
page, where you can
customize your instance
and choose a name, a zone,
a machine type, a boot disk
image, network access,
and additional options
like management, disk
networking, access,
and security options.
The defaults are
designed to work well,
so we'll simply select Deploy,
and you're ready to go.
To get started with
EDB Postgres Enterprise
on Cloud Launcher, click on
the link in the comments.
Thanks for watching.